hello everyone and welcome to pi data
global 2021 my name is camila and i'm
going to be your moderator for this
session and i would like now to welcome
uh ankit hattie
and
yatim batya and they are going to give a
talk to us on best practicing machine
learning uh observer
observability uh ankit rati is a data
science architect published author and
well-known speaker
and yatim bhatia is an associate
director of data science at
relogix three
sorry i thought the name wrong you can
correct me that you got me
welcome
hi everyone so um the session is on best
practices in machine learning
observability
camera has already provided some
introduction but yeah
so so i am yatim bhatia and along with
me it's ankit so we have roughly 16
years of fight experience and eight
years in data science
okay so agenda of our discussion um so
first first uh section will be context
and introduction so what what we are
talking about that
i will go through and after that the
best practices the main main discussion
the main topic of our talk that is best
practices in ml observability that ankit
will go through
so so let me start with uh what is ml
observability and then after that will
take over with the best practices so
i will i will start with with some
basics because there can be some
newcomers who do not know about machine
learning
so uh what is what is machine learning
and
and uh
why why the machine learning came into
picture so previously we have
traditional programming
in which we have some input and we have
some we have to write some program
program is what it's a set of rules
and then some computation happened and
then we got the result but we have to
write the rules of ourselves
what machine learning has done
right provide the machine learning
system as an input as well as the
desired result the previous results
whatever we have in the past
and then some computation will happen
and this system will it shall provide
you the rules
now these rules are the system generated
rules and then after after these rules
are generated you can use it uh further
to to get the result because
you don't have to generate the rules the
system is generated the rules so that is
effectively a machine learning
i guess broadly the audience knows it
but it is just for setting up the
context
machine learning is
more than just smaller training that i
have written here in this slide
so what i want to illustrate it is okay
uh this black box the rectangular box
it's very small in size
so this is effectively the model
training part
the core of machine learning that's the
modern training but if you see there are
a lot of big rectangles on the left side
above below right side
so these also are the uh part and parcel
of complete data science paradigm the
complete you know uh getting the
requirement and then building the
product and shipping the product the
deploying the product
a machine learning product like data
collection feature expression process
management tools configuration
monitoring
data verification
serving infrastructure like at the last
level so we have to deploy the things
and we have to we have to scale up the
things so
all these things compute a lot more than
just a model training part that that is
what illustrated in this butler
in this particular picture
yeah
okay
so while uh machine learning model is
prepared so now now i am going uh
towards our main topic the ml monitoring
ml observability
so while machine learning model is in
production
so many things can happen
uh so so one thing can happen that is
that data drift
so there is a drift in the distribution
of the data
like how how the data is distributed
previously i am talking in the left side
of the
picture i am talking here about the
univariate distribution
like if you see
the distribution of data is like blue
earlier and
now it is like red
so there can be like multiple examples
in real life wherever you will talk
there is always a drift in the data
for example the the drift data which we
collect before march 2020 or the
lockdown or the kovit 19 that is all
together different
and the data collected after march 2020
is all to the different
the distribution the univated
distribution of the data is different
so here what is data data can be like
you know if you are considering tabular
data so
for in tablet data the way that data has
been generated so that can be different
one feature or a combination of features
that can be uh different the the the the
spending habits of persons or anything
that changes actually like how much
person spent before before march 2020
and after march 2020 that is all
together different
so this shows the
drift in the data
now why we are considering this why we
are reading this this drift in that data
may cause
bad predictions in my model because my
model is prepared according to the blue
one
now data is coming according to the red
one this may cause bad predictions to my
model so it is important for me to
unders to understand the distributions
of both kind of data once my model is in
the production i have to compare what i
have done in that training part and what
is there in a production part
accordingly i have to change my model
second on the right side of figure is
concept drift
so now what is concept drift so this is
distribution of data and in here we are
considering the output variable as well
like this is the data and
the green one is the one one class and
the red one is the one class
it has been properly distributed uh
sorry properly segregated like one class
with other class
simple classification scenario
and then this figure regime b
here also green has red red is there
that
data is there you know distribution uh
but but the distribution of y the output
variable as according to the input
variable has completely changed
earlier it's like you know separated
vertically now it's separated
horizontally so
so this needs to be encoded back
encountered back into the model my model
has to be retrained re-engineered
again needs to be prepared
so this this concept is also very very
important but
only thing is data drift you don't have
to
you don't have to get the cred you don't
have to get the truth levels uh while
you are in production you can still do
the data drift while uh you are not
having the
truth truth data that the the output
labels but for concept drift
the truth data the true data is always
important
because you need to segregate which is
green and which is red
another example of i have written the
short note here so concept uh suppose
concept rate of a data variable like uh
mobile number uh has been changed so
what is the concept here is uh so
previously i have a mobile number in my
data in my tableau data and from that
mobile number i am able to
able to compute them which is a telecom
operator for this mobile number
but now what what the concept has been
changes uh mobile number portability has
been introduced into that particular
region or deadpool.country
so previously i am able to get the
number operator through some mechanism
now when i will get the moment number
operator uh i do not know about whether
uh
whether the mobile number portability is
there or not but now i will get the
wrong
wrong telecom operator
so there is a drift and that client
needs to tell me that there is a drift
in the concept
okay resolution for it we will we will
cover later but this is effectively data
drift and concept drift
then data quality the quality of the
data if if the quality of the data
changes while i am in production as
compared to while i've done the model
training part that that also causes
issues
qualities cover each and every aspect
how whether the data is complete it is
consistent it is relevant
all those things business impact
of course there is a business impact if
there is a drift in the data data drift
if their concept director is there and
my accuracies changes my afferent score
is changes so businesses will not be
happy with that
and i have to change something because
we are we are getting money for these
models and if models are not behaving
properly we have to do something
yeah
okay monitoring and observability so um
so monitoring is uh one thing that you
are monitoring the things okay you are
getting things you are viewing the graph
okay
this has been changed data drift is
there concept drift is there something
hasn't changed you are able to monitor
it but uh observability is more than
monitoring observability is you have to
do some actions you have you have to you
have to apply some feedback mechanism so
that next time when the predictions will
go on this you will encounter this drift
and then you will you will again
not be in the loop the predictions are
wrong
next time the petition should be correct
because you you have taken this feedback
so
for uh
observability is more than monitoring
possibility is like applying feedback
back to the model training part so if
you see there is a there is a arrow from
modern melting to model training part
this is observability it is not obvious
just uh just like you know
you got to know what are the things but
now you are applying actions on top of
that
if if you can see in this figure also so
monitoring is a tip part of the iceberg
seeing the seeing the things the action
part feedback part is the observability
that is the bottom of the iceberg that
is the main part
okay so what are the what are the uh
techniques uh to do this so basically
monitor the performance of the model so
we have to monitor that drift regularly
data trip concept any data quality
issues
and you have to analyze some metrics so
a lot of metrics are there out of the
box statistical distributions are there
okay
in that monitoring part you got some
metrics like psi score population
stability index
your confidence scores are in the range
of 60 to 70 to 80 percent
and now in the production your
confidence score are in the range of 60
to 70 percent so these are some of the
clear-cut metrics
which will give you okay there's a drift
in the data
root call analysis so you have to
determine what
why this script has been occurred so
whether business has not told you or it
is something like in the pipeline
something else
apply feedback the most important part
you have determined the drift uh but you
have to you have to uh you know
apply the feedback mechanism and then so
that next time the model will provide
the prediction it will not it will cause
only the good predictions it will not
cause the bad predictions
yeah so that's it from my set so um i
will have sunk it so you can take over
from this point
okay you can share your screen okay or
uh or i can just uh control the screen
yeah yeah sure
thank you
okay so we have learned the basics of
machine learning and the need of
observability from there again and we'll
capture the best practices here
so very first part is the cultural
change we'll go through each
point uh one by one but i'm just
mentioning the outline here so first
part is the
cultural change second part is
monitoring your data
monitoring your models monitoring your
predictions
optimization of the alerts and logging
everything that matters for the solution
so
next slide
okay so as a part of cultural change
what we need to do is we need to feed
the data like a product so there should
be some ownership and accountability
where
we can track the changes in the data
we can assess quality we can
check
the lineage of the data
we can benchmark the quality and we can
monitor the drift
the second is decentralizing the
knowledge so if
the machine learning observability
current can't be assigned to a single
person because once the solution scales
then it will overburden
and
it is a team effort
there are few things it's a kind of
monitoring plus feedback loop
there are very
different stages where we need to
take different actions
which would be overwhelming for one
person so
it is a kind of team effort where
the task needs to be divided among the
team on on the different part of the
solution
now
including the observability
from
experimentation itself so it's not like
once we go to uh production we deploy
the model in production and then
observability come into picture we need
to take care of if we are seriously
looking
for model performance and we want to
tackle that we need to take care of
observability from the experimentation
itself
so
another part is monitoring your data
so we need to
keep our batch and streaming pipeline
similar because like if anything changes
to the batch
because the pipelines are built
on a similar manner so we need to apply
those changes into streaming as well
because whatever is your training
that
data will also go the similar kind of
data will also go for
the prediction purpose and so if we keep
the pipelines
in the same way then the troubleshooting
will be easier and it will be more
intuitive to the overall
landscape
uh second part is
apart from the
data drift we need to focus on the
feature drift as well to get the more
insights because
we can have many features and all the
data
some of the data elements may be
shifting
or drifting apart but those might not be
your features or those might not be your
important features so to basically
prioritize which are the features or
which is the data part or the data
element that we need to
focus more than other others
it's like we need to focus on the
feature drift then the data drift itself
if we are
using data from different
data sources then we need to maintain a
global data catalog as well
which makes the data lineage easier we
can
understand this like from where the data
elements are coming how those are being
transformed and in what format
those are available to us
we can also track the quality of the
data
and it will also help us to measure the
baseline of the data quality so that we
can compare
with the baseline later on and see miss
like whether the data quality is has
improved or deteriorated
so monitoring your models
when you deploy the model in production
it's not always that it will
[Music]
the performance will uh
keep up to the mark or maybe it will it
will go up or down
so we need to anticipate that there may
be a big deal in the performance and
if we can automate that part it
makes the job a lot easier
apart from that we can maintain pin
model approach where
we can put the champion model in
production and challenges challenger
model in reprod
the idea is
because we need to drain the model again
and again and
not a single strategy work
for a longer way
as the data rift happens or the scenario
changes so we need to have a challenger
model as well which we can take it up to
pre-prod and maybe image like suppose we
have updated our model um on a weekly or
monthly basis we can put the it in the
pre-prod environment for some time and
see
performance of both the champion model
as well as the challenger model and if
it's like uh the challenger model is
better we can uh
reverse the role it's like we can make
it champion and put it into production
and
the champion becomes a challenger so it
basically
uh takes care of
having
different models for the same cause
without making much changes um post
production
another thing that we can do is so you
can version maintain hyper parameters
for easier troubleshooting because
as
the data is in
production
and
it is drifting so apart from the data
version changes
we are also changing our algorithm and
especially the hyper parameters so if we
version maintain them it will become
easier to troubleshoot
if anything goes wrong next slide please
now another thing is monitoring your
predictions so we need to watch out for
the prediction drift
but we can't solely rely on that
because
not in every scenario we get the ground
truth so at once just like sometimes we
get it five minutes late sometimes we
get it
a day minutes late uh
sometimes we get a month
late
so uh if we see a drift in product
prediction so we can solely on that we
can say that there is a drift and it's a
bad thing for our model unless we have
the ground truth
and we see the drift there as well
another
uh aspect is tracking and dealing with
the unreasonable output of the model so
um we don't have rule-based logics in
the model right like based on the data
itself is it matches the patterns and
detect the patterns and provide the
output and if there is something wrong
with the input then output may be
very re
for some time so it's our job to
make a note of
these kind of unreasonable outputs from
the model and put some kind of business
logic on top of that so that it's like
it's
it can make more sense for the business
user
now
um
having logs and alerts
gives us
an advantage if anything goes wrong and
while we can have
the alerts too many or two less but we
need to define what is the optimum level
of alerts just like if the alerts are
too less then basically we
we can
miss some important alerts which needs
to be monitored and if we have too many
then maybe miss like some kind of uh
important alert maybe get missed into
low priority alerts so we need to
basically keep the alerts to its optimum
level
and we need to test these alerts uh
before moving to prediction
because of many reasons so that the team
is
accustomed to the alerts that is being
generated or the person who is
monitoring it
uh knows miss like what kind of alerts
can be generated and how to interpret it
and how to take action or they raise a
red flag on that
and we also need to agree on a format or
a
what kind of plots and charts are being
generated as part of alerts so that
the person who is monitoring it can make
sense of it
another
last important
aspect is logging everything that
matters so
there are few things that we need to
take care of like logging the runtimes
the number of runs
job failures
and we also need to lock
the prediction alongside with the ground
truth so it helps really
if uh um the the prediction is drifting
or maybe the model performance is going
down then we can see okay what was the
ground truth and what was our prediction
and was like how
uh last month or last day of last week
what was the difference and now what is
the difference so it helps a lot to
make a sense of that
then
logging the data and model version as
well because over the period of time we
will be
the data will drift
and even we will be making changes to
the model as well so we need to uh keep
a track of the changes in the data and
model as well uh it will help immensely
if something goes wrong and we need to
troubleshoot
so basically these are the best
practices for
ml observability and we are open for
questions
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much jacquin for your presentation we
have a couple of questions in the chat
uh pedro is asking if you're going to
share the presentation with us later on
in the talks channel or here in the chat
um
you can do yeah
we can do that here
when considering from alexander weed
when considering feature drift what
metrics would you recommend to use and
what would you consider significant
drift so the threshold to take action
so actually that is quite dependent on
the problem
you are working in whether it's a
classification problem or regression
problem
and
the threshold is also defined just like
uh
from the problem itself just like uh
when we test the model uh in in a
testing environment then we uh discuss
with the users
just like what uh what are the threshold
that should be taken it's like which are
the when you see this like the
model performance is going down because
it's quite subjective for some use cases
99 accuracy may be enough
for some use cases 85 80 percent
accuracy may be enough and somewhere
like
false negatives and false positives
these are also
become important so it's really
subjective to the problem that we are
working on
i see adam has a question and uh yatin
is answering on the chat we go i go for
the question of adam do you have any
tips to deal with extremely delayed
ground truth example uh one year
particularly for logging prediction
alongside ground through
yeah so um
that's a good question uh generally
means like if the
ground truth is available as soon as we
have made the prediction it makes the
job easier
but
yeah it's like in many scenarios we get
the ground truth later on so we need to
lock them separately once we have the
ground proof the idea is to have the
ground truth and the prediction
which do is so that we can see miss like
how much gap is there and
if the gap has increased or decreased
over the period of time
if the ground truth is available later
on then basically we can't do anything
it's like it's just that we can maybe
monitor the prediction drift itself but
as i mentioned earlier we can't uh
surely take an action
uh based on the prediction drift alone
okay uh we have also one here from
jeremy
in
great thanks for your presentation in
monitor your data is live you said
measure the baseline of data quality how
do you define in the baseline what do
you measure exactly for example
okay
so
measuring the baseline means in the data
quality is basically
you have
a data and
there are various aspects like
correctness
truthfulness of the data how it is
varying up across its domain
so there are
data quality parameters where we can
rank our data
and uh based on that we can see okay for
a particular column how many uh how much
values are null
how much
many values are outliers and it's like
so those kind of uh stats we can collect
from the data itself it's like obviously
this like these kind of distribution
will be different from for
um
for the
variables that are quantitative and
qualitative but basically we can keep um
uh matrix of uh uh these as a baseline
that uh
at the initial stage this is our data
quality so that if anything goes wrong
we can again collect the same thing
similar kind of stats from the data and
compare it with maybe suppose just a
crude example is like earlier we had
five percent
nulls in one column now we have uh
maybe even like uh 20 nulls in the
column and then we can start analyzing
why that happened
okay our time is over now thank you so
much ankit thank you so much hatching
for your talk if you would like you can
continue the discussion at uh gather
town or in the talks channel thank you
so much for being at pi data global
2021.
yeah see me yeah have a nice day bye